escucharás a personas hablar de
diferentes maneras de ver el pib y en
general hablarán del pib visto desde el
punto de vista de los gastos y ver sus
versos el punto de vista de los ingresos
el pib visto desde el punto de vista de
los ingresos entonces bueno para ver por
qué estas dos te llevan al mismo número
en el pib pero porque conceptualmente
estás viendo cosas distintas
visitaremos una economía sencilla quizás
un poco más complicada que aquella
economía con una isla en los vídeos
pasados pero bueno esta será un poco más
complicada en esta economía habrá varios
ocupantes de la casa entonces habrá
varios no como en aquella economía que
era más sencilla y también habrá varias
fábricas entonces bueno vamos a suponer
por simplicidad digamos que ellos son
los dueños de todos los factores de
producción de todos los factores de
producción y después se las van a rentar
las empresas le rentan esos factores de
producción a las empresas para que ellas
produzcan todos los bienes y servicios
producen todos los bienes y servicios
esto que estamos diciendo son
suposiciones fuertes que no son
en el mundo real simplemente se hace
sencillo dibujar este diagrama y bueno
en el mundo real los ocupantes de la
casa no son dueños de todos los factores
de producción pero bueno al final del
día no estamos asumiendo algo tan tan
loco tan fuera de lugar porque al final
de cuentas a quién le pertenecen las
empresas las empresas le pertenecen a
las personas así que en teoría pudieron
ser transferidos a los ocupantes luego
ellos rentan los factores de producción
a las empresas y también es una asunción
simple porque sabemos que en el mundo
real las empresas no producen todos los
bienes y servicios sabemos que también
los ocupantes producen bienes y
servicios como por ejemplo
hace la jardinería prepara una rica cena
el servicio de cuidar a los hijos son
cosas que no se contabilizan en el pib
entonces bueno nada de esto se
contabiliza pero por simplicidad
asumamos esto todos los factores de
producción hagamos una lista de ellos el
trabajo tenemos el trabajo la tierra el
capital
el espíritu empresarial también todo
esto lo da el dueño el ocupante de la
casa y todos los bienes y servicios son
producidos por las empresas y vimos en
el ejemplo de la isla que los ocupantes
de la casa hacen todos estos gastos que
terminaban siendo los ingresos para la
empresa luego las empresas toman esos
ingresos y los gastan para rentar a
algunos de los factores que tenemos aquí
en la lista algunos de ellos entonces
por ejemplo ellos dan en lo que es el
empleo a personas así que dan trabajo
rentan tierra en renta en capital y ya
con todo eso todo eso termina siendo
ingresos para los ocupantes ingresos
para los ocupantes en esa dirección van
los gastos de las fábricas así que
tomamos esos ingresos y esos ingresos se
convierten en gastos y ganancias lo que
sea que sobre de los gastos es ganancia
también estamos asumiendo que todas las
empresas le pertenecen a los ocupantes
por lo tanto los gastos más ganancias
acaban siendo de los ocupantes como
ingresos lo cual después se convierte en
gastos
en gastos para el ocupante que después
se convierten en ingresos para la
empresa ingresos así que gastos en el
pib ver sus ingresos en el pib aquí lo
que está diciendo es que el pip se puede
medir en cualquiera de estos dos puntos
puedo medirlo desde el punto de vista de
gastos del ocupante de la casa en este
modelo sencillo que es lo mismo a
ingresos en las fábricas en este modelo
que es lo mismo que gastos más ganancias
en las empresas y en lo cual es lo mismo
que ingresos en los ocupantes todo es lo
mismo así que el pib desde el punto de
vista de los gastos es lo mismo como tú
puedes ver no importa desde que desde
qué punto de vista yo lo vea va a dar el
mismo número aunque en este ejemplo
sencillo para lo tome para mostrarte que
estos dos son exactamente lo mismo con
respecto al pib pero entonces puedes ver
el pib desde el punto de vista que tú
quieras si quisiéramos verlo desde el
punto de vista de los ingresos también
lo podemos hacer entonces bueno en
vídeos siguientes vamos a ver cómo todo
cuadra con el consumo en inversión
gastos del gobierno exportaciones netas
veremos que no es tan sencillo
hacerlo en el diagrama pero cuando
pensamos en eso cuando hablamos de
consumo de inversión gastos de gobierno
estamos pensando desde el punto de vista
de los gastos y hay otra manera de verlo
el ingreso agregado eso es desde el
punto de vista de el país para
importaciones y exportaciones pero ojalá
bueno esto deje claro porque no importa
desde el punto de vista donde veas al
pib te dará el mismo número ingresos y
gastos para el pib dan lo mismo a la
hora de calcular